Build It.
Draw It.
Play It.
Vsauce!
Kevin here with some of the coolest creations
from extraordinary people.
This is BiDiPi.
Li Hongbo creates paper illusions by glueing
together hundreds of sheets of paper.
The flexible sculptures appear solid but they
can bend, stretch, fold, or contract.
His inspiration came from festive “paper
gourds” which are common decorations in
China.
And his most recent work involves cutting
silhouettes from butcher knives.
Students at MIT resurrected their old tradition
of incoming freshman constructing a wooden
roller coaster.
They were given a week to complete it and
they initially planned to include a loop de
loop but were forced to scrap that idea because
the environment, health, and safety department
said no upside down students...period.
Tim Baker built a Groot Swing.
The Guardians Of The Galaxy swing set was
constructed from wood, metal, and high density
foam.
Tim has been a Hollywood set and prop builder
for 25 years and the video is part of a new
Super-Fan Builds series on the AweMe Channel.
Victor Poulin hand-makes boomerangs based
on weapons from movies and video games such
as the Glaive from Krull, Hell’s Retriever
from Call of Duty Black ops 2, and Sokka’s
Boomerang from Avatar the Last Airbender.
He carves each of them out of high-quality
birch and you can buy them on his website.
DRAW IT
Maria Malone-Guerbaa is a makeup artist who
can completely change her face.
Using nothing by face paint she’s able to
transform into celebrities like Stevie Wonder
and Clint Eastwood, fictional characters like
Elsa from Frozen and even animals like a baby
seal, snow leopard and a reindeer.
Aside from working professionally on various
tv shows and movies she also teaches workshops
on the art of makeup.
Mitch Gobel creates abstract resin art to
support wildlife conservation.
He's auctioning off 25 of his artwork pieces
that use a one-of-a-kind resin lacing technique
in order to raise money to protect Australian
Rainforests and also to fulfill his dream
of starting his own Wildlife Conservation
Company.
And now the work of Douggy who takes iconic
characters and re-imagines them in a drippy
way.
Jerobeam Fenderson draws moving pictures with
sound.
Using an analog oscilloscope he sends sound
into left and right audio tracks to sculpt
various images like a mushroom forest complete
with a moving butterfly.
Successfully blending math, science and art.
PLAY IT
Sonya Belousova plays an arrangement of the
Tetris Theme on a custom piano made from pinball
machines.
Freak Kitchen’s music video for “Freak
of the Week” is awesomely animated by former
Disney animator Juanjo Guarnido.
Yuki Koshimoto travels the world selling her
jewelry and playing the spacedrum.
Finally, Teenage Exorcists by Mogwai masterfully
blends practical and digital effects and is
directed by Craig Murray.
Inspiration also comes from you.
Vsauce Creative Fan Showcase.
First up is Essick with Ghost Towns.
Let's go!
Darius Hamilton hand-paints custom shoes for
his website paintmysole.com.
He uses a high quality leather paint and takes
specific requests from customers.
After four years Jamie Staff has finished
the Terminator T-800 Endoskeleton.
I featured the arm back in BiDiPi #45 and
now the fully-articulated cast aluminum creation
is complete.
Abe N. draws intricate doodles on eggs.
He’s an engineering student that creates
the artwork and photographs as a hobby.
Artifexian explains how to mathematically
build a plausible binary star system like
Tatooine from Star Wars.
Here’s Neowx with Release The Kraken Pt.
Quroaki is a circuit and app that turns your
phone into a robot.
Created by Oedelin Jean on his bedroom floor
he's made the circuit public for everyone
to use.
Here's some fractal artwork from Atif.
Ryan Carter built a Minecraft christmas tree
with a control system for RGB LEDs that change
the color on his actual Christmas tree.
Submit your BiDiPis to BiDiPi@Vsauce.com to
share them with everyone on Twitter with hashtag
BiDiPi.
And as always - thanks for watching!